[THEME MUSIC]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: So I've
always been fascinated
by the relationship between
creativity and madness, right?
Like Timothy Leary
famously said, in order
to use your head, you've
got to go out of your mind.
Now this of course implies
a kind of willingness
to sort of go to unknown places,
to visit mental landscapes that
are alien.
A willingness to sort of
leave one's comfort zone,
to decondition one's
thinking, one's
reflexive responses
to stimuli; to go
to other realms of the mind.
Catalyzing the imagination
is like diving head-first
towards the unknown.
And there's always a
potential of getting hurt.
You know, it is said that
the mystic and the madman
are swimming in the same waters.
But the mystic, he's like
an artist surfing it down.
He's bringing back visions.
He's bringing back souvenirs
from these ecstatic spaces
and places.
But at the end of the day, the
artist does become depleted.
The artist is sacrificing
part of himself
to bring back those visions,
to create a phase change
in the consciousness of society.
He leaves the consensus trance.
He leaves our cultural
operating systems.
He shows us different
reality tunnels that gives us
a sense of perspective.
Us as consumers of art, we
pay money for them to take us
to spaces that we
cannot go by ourselves.
These are heroes.
These are cultural luminaries.
They are madmen
that somehow have
been able to sort of
coax and domesticate
their madness towards ends.
This idea of always
having functional output.
To go to Oz, to tumble
down that rabbit hole,
and somehow return
to tell the tale.
[MUSIC PLAYING]